in the current situation of the world
pretty much the whole world being
in kind of lockdown um we know that
certain
tech firms have been working on uh
contact tracing
technology to try and help people
work out who they've been in contact
with so we've got steve and mike here
um steve uh what's the deal here
with the obvious medical situation at
the moment i'm not going to use the c
word because we'll probably get
demonetised and things if we do
there's a lot of talk about how we could
use technology
to sort of try and trace people who may
have it and who they've been in contact
with and i thought it's interesting
particularly as apple and google have
been working on technology to do this
to just have a conversation about this i
mean it's sort of an interesting
application of technologies that exist
on the phone i mean if you
would sit and think about how you would
do this then understood the technology
then you'd come up with pretty much the
same
approach that apple and google have come
up with but the idea is is that
i'm walking along the street mike walks
past me
my phone and his phone talk to each
other and then later mike goes down with
some sort of nasty disease
he notifies the phone which notifies the
local health service
and then that can tell me that i've just
been infected by someone
hopefully preserving privacy and then
i can then go into self-isolation so
that if i develop it i don't pass it on
to anyone else that's the general idea
some sort of automated way so if someone
suddenly finds out
that they've become infected because
they start to show symptoms they can
notify the people they may have been in
contact both the ones they know
but also the ones they've met in the
aisle at sainsbury's as they're picking
up the baked beans
or whatever it is they might be so it's
a way of sort of keeping track of that
in an easy way so it sounds like you've
sort of hit the nail on the head there
this is kind of
it's tracking what people are doing but
then you've got to somehow preserve
privacy
um yeah maybe that's the point to bring
mike in on this
um sure that's like that's like the
two sides of one coin isn't it yeah i
mean
the privacy is a real problem uh in the
sense that and i mean i should say that
actually i'm not against this app
or any of these apps in general i think
obviously trying to prevent the spread
of a disease is obviously a good thing
to do
um i think that we we should probably
separate what
in our heads would be a perfect system
from what a system might that might
actually exist
is the issue with privacy is that so
google and apple's approach is you know
fairly private in the sense that
you don't give away who you are you just
give away keys and maybe we can talk
about that in a moment
and it means that you can be told that
you are in contact with someone who
maybe has tested positive for this
disease
but you probably can't find out
necessarily who that is
but even that system isn't completely
private i mean if i
hypothetically if lockdown was eased out
eased up a little bit and i went around
to steve's house for half a day
and then i get a message later on my
phone that says someone on that day
that you're in contact with has been
exposed to some virus well
it's not going to take great deductive
reasoning for me to work out who that
was
so it is private but only to an extent
like there are ways around this
there are some conundrums around it but
let's should we talk about in
hypothetically or in principle how might
something like this work yes i mean the
approach that
they're taking the google and apple are
suggesting we take and
all the other um approaches that are
being taken are relatively
straightforward i mean
most of us carry around with us these
days some form of smartphone either an
android phone or an iphone whatever it
is that takes your fancy
uh and these come with bluetooth built
in and one of the features particularly
of bluetooth
for bluetooth low energy that they offer
it's the ability
for low-power devices to sort of sit
around the environment and transmit to
say that they are there so
apple have used this with their ibeacons
technology other places have used this
so that
if you walk into a shop that can then
say to your phone you're in mark
suspenses or whatever it is and then
that can bring up information on your
phone
relevant to the local area so you can do
some hyperloop listings you could use it
in your house
so if you say your phone turn on the
lights it knows which room you're in and
turns on the right set of lights rather
than having to say turn on the
lights in the lounge or whatever it is
the approach that they're taking is that
they take this
technology and make all phones regularly
say every five minutes send out an
advertisement with a specific
code in it that says this is for
exposure tracing
so your phone will send something out
and then all the other phones in the
area will receive that
and they know they've seen that phone
i've got a little demonstration set up
using
a raspberry pi here this raspberry pi is
actually sending out
advertisements not of the exposure
tracing type but just generic
advertisements using some of the free
software that came with blues on linux
and i've got my phone here running an
app which can
show you what things can be seen at the
moment so if i look at this at the
moment
we can see down here at the bottom as
well as seeing my
all my devices there's one called happy
which is what happens to be the name
of that raspberry pi and alongside that
in very small letters
it tells us the rssi effectively it's a
sort of proxy for how far away
that device is so at the moment it's
showing that as being minus 42
if i move the device over here it's gone
to minus 60.
as well as since that device is in the
same room we can also get some sort of
idea
of how far away it is from the person
which means that we can also say well
actually
if it's too far away then they're not
likely to have been in close enough
contact
to caught the virus and so we'll just
ignore that because
imagine you're walking down a street you
may well
have line of sight to someone the other
side of the road and so you won't
necessarily pick anything up from that
so there's no point in recording that on
the other hand
if i'm sitting on the bus next to
someone then
you would definitely want to know about
it because the chances are it's a little
tricky because
if you hold the phone in different
directions it's in your back pocket and
the other person's back pocket you'll
get different types
of sort of readings off there but you
get some sort of sense
so that can tell us what's in the same
area and the idea that google and apple
is saying is
okay every time we
get one of those advertisements we note
down who it is
and we can build up a big table on the
phone that says i have seen
this phone at this time and you can then
extend it if you see it five minutes
later and so on you can get an idea of
who you've seen and for how long you've
been exposed to them a very fleeting
limits as you walk past someone on the
street
you probably will never get picked up
and never recorded being in the same
shop
for 10 minutes while you're doing your
shopping probably will get recorded and
things that's the sort of thing you want
to know
because that fleeting glance as you walk
past probably not going to pass anything
on
at all now you need to do some way of
knowing who that so you could just give
everyone in the world a number
um i'd be number six you could be number
might could be number two that sort of
thing but the problem with that is
then becomes very easy to say who's been
in contact with who
and you don't really need that
information to contact trace to
detect exposure as a way of doing this
you just need to know that
he's been in contact to be the other
thing that apple and google have
suggested is a way of anonymizing
this so that i know i've been exposed to
someone
but i don't know who it is and there
really isn't an easy way without
other information i i was on this bus at
this time
and so on to actually de-anonymize it as
i see it's a bit like sona or radar with
a bit more information so you know
you've got these
a bit like transponders on planes where
everybody has some kind of number and
you can say okay you met number two
number three
you went past number one but it wasn't
very close et cetera et cetera if i got
that about right
that's right you know who everyone is
they're in the same area
you've got a record they were in the
same area and then number six gets
some particular weird thing
you can then broadcast out to everyone
else
this identifier had this and then they
can check their databases or you could
upload the databases into a central
place
and they could then say to each other
you've been exposed you probably should
go into self-isolation or something
for whatever the requirement is for the
particular
malady that is being traced at that
point and so on
that makes me think uh people are gonna
be
worried about these numbers and how we
work out who's what number so mike how
are people gonna work out who these
numbers are without telling people who
they are
and yeah all that sort of stuff yeah so
actually it's quite simple
um and it's quite a clever way of doing
it we don't obviously send
any individual identifiers out right
it's just it your
your phone is sending messages but
they're not messages that can be used to
identify you
so i mean to use a very simple example
let's imagine that our applications were
just sending out our names
then you could just use any phone to
sniff on anyone walking past that day
right which is
probably an invasion of privacy right so
um what we do instead is your phone will
every 24 hours generates something
called
a temporary exposure key and that is
essentially a secret key that you're
going to keep
and you're only ever going to send it
out if you get diagnosed with some virus
that you want to notify people about
so from that key you combine that with
the current time
in a sort of rolling window of about 10
minutes
and every sort of 10 or 15 minutes
you'll take your temporary exposure key
and the current time and you'll combine
them using encryption
into your actual rolling proximity
identifier or rpi
and that thing is the thing you actually
transmit out using this bluetooth what
will happen is
you'll be out and about and you'll just
get sent random rolling proximity
identifiers which are just meaningless
numbers
and you can then stash them away on your
phone for a later date
now let's imagine that i'm going out and
about and i've created some of these
rolling proximity identifiers
what happens if i go to a doctor and i
get the disease and i
have to notify people who i've been in
contact with what i do is i
upload to the cloud or up to you know
the health authority or whoever it is
that's running the app
i upload my temporary exposure keys the
daily keys that i was using
and then everyone else's phones will
occasionally go up to the cloud and ask
for any temporary exposure keys that
have been released that day
or for the last few days and they will
use those to generate
given the time that those were released
the different
potential rolling identifier keys of
rolling proximity identifiers that could
have occurred
based on that temporary exposure key and
if
if one matches then your phone now knows
that you've been exposed theoretically
to some disease by being in bluetooth
contact with someone
who has now sort of said i've got it
right
so what you actually basically get is a
bunch of meaningless numbers
but once you get these temporary
exposure keys from a sort of reputable
source
your phone can sort of back calculate
what those rpis would have been
and go oh actually i i did see that one
that means i've probably been exposed
now in the google and apple model this
is a decentralized process so a decision
as to whether to alert you or something
like this is going to be made on your
phone
based on for example the signal strength
which is included in the packet
and things like how long you're in
contact with them for and stuff like
this
other sort of you know other health
services and other
companies and you know governments and
things are working on slightly different
systems which are centralized by design
which would have that kind of decision
put into the cloud
with many more people involved
computationally isn't that really quite
expensive i mean
if you're potentially looking through
trying to
calculate i'm guessing what will be kind
of like a hash on every possible time
stamp that your phone has been there
on every possible released is it is that
am i right there
so so i mean if you think that the
um for for the current pandemic the sort
of suggestion is that maybe you're
contagious for maybe 14 days
so you're not going to bother releasing
all of your ever you know all of your
temporary exposure keys that you've ever
produced
right if you've been running this app
for a year so you
you know you get diagnosed you release
let's say a maximum of 14 of these keys
there's 144 of these 10 or 15 minute
windows
in a day so you've got that 14 times
that many
possible encryptions that you've got to
perform per key right
so it is it is an issue computationally
but it's not it's not a disaster right
and you're only going to do it once per
key either you've seen it or you haven't
um and so you know it's it's doable
right but this is you know this is going
to be an overhead there's going to be an
overhead involved in doing this
you only have to work out whether it's
worth alerting the user
if you find the key so you know you
download the temporary exposure key
you perform the encryption you generate
the potential rpis and you compare them
with the ones you've seen
and if you get a hit that's when you
start looking more in a more complicated
way
things like signal strength and things
like this so you don't do all that
unless you got this
this cryptographic hit and you said okay
i actually was you know connected to
that phone
you know at least briefly and there's
other things you can do of course of
course for example
if you decide the exposure of less than
say
five minutes isn't harmful
let's say let's say that for some reason
you need to be exposed for
15 minutes within two meters you can
already start to throw away that data on
your local device
um if you know that that's not the case
you know that i've only seen this
identifier for three minutes
i guess it's an issue it may have
changed midway through that but
you've only seen it for three minutes
then i'm not going to be
needing this i can throw it away and
things and so on you've also got data on
there
there's a limit to how much data you
have to be able to hold on to at the
same time right it's not none but it's
not and these are small messages i mean
these are sort of 16 byte messages
so you know it's not a huge amount of
memory either
i mean every text message you send is
going to be bigger than this and if we
think about the way some people text
uh every email is going to be massively
bigger than this
i mean the text message will be at least
10 times bigger than this
an email probably 100 times bigger than
this just in the headers and things so
it's really small amounts of data
i think i was worried that if i'm
thinking of every possible time
in every possible day and then trying to
calculate a hash based upon
a potential of how many thousand keys
released and
just see what i mean i was more thinking
of if i've got to be
making those it's not the same as going
right okay
over this period of time did i see
number six number two and number three
it's actually did i see number six
hashed with the time
yeah so there is there is an additional
amount of work because you've got to
take that temporary exposure key and
combine it with all the different
possible times that that key was
because each key comes with a sort of
approximate day but it was active
and so you've got maybe 144 different
encryptions you're going to have to
perform
obviously you're only receiving new
exposure keys
from the cloud so maybe 10 people have
used the app that day and so you've only
got 10 of these to do but then maybe a
million people have usually haven't been
diagnosed that day it's not been a good
one
and now you've got a lot more encryption
you've got to do but again you've also
got
extra data though so you can sort of you
know the phone knows where it's been
location-wise so it can start to give
say
this one never left liverpool or this
one never left
balamori or somewhere the google and
apple model what they're doing is
they're releasing an api which will
allow you to do these things this
bluetooth message passing and
this key generation on the device but
they're not providing an app that will
do
contact tracing or any kind of public
service you know public health
announcements or anything like that what
they're assuming is that
countries or you know the nhs or some
other hospital will implement a system
like this
and use this api so actually there isn't
very much
information held in these messages all
you get is
you know someone has been diagnosed or
reportedly been diagnosed with this
virus
and you were in contact with them for
this window of time because of this
bluetooth signal
what do you do right that that's a very
good question i get a message on my
phone that says someone has been exposed
to some virus
and you've had a brief amount of contact
with them but you don't know who it is
or where this was
it's impossible to know whether i should
be self quarantining or not right i mean
maybe it's gone through a wall
and it was just you know a neighbor or
something like that and i've not
actually had any physical contact with
them without more information it's nice
and private in some sense you know it's
difficult to trace where everyone's been
going and with whom
but it's difficult to get a big picture
of what's going on with
the spread of a pandemic or something
like this which is why
some countries looking for slightly more
information like gps locations and
actual names and addresses and
you know contact with gps and things
like this
um to build a much bigger picture of
what's going on
and that's where i think people start to
decide you know how much
privacy should we be giving away even
temporarily for something like this
but yes so some governments have said
basically if we're going to do proper
contact tracing we want more information
than this
right we would like gps we'd like who
your family members are you know
where i mean this is the same kind of
contact tracing they would do anyway
right if i got
a disease that needed to be traced
they would ask me personally who i'd
been in contact with i'd tell them and
they'd phone them up and ask them as
well right so
in some sense what they're building into
their the additional information they're
building into these applications
isn't anything we're not kind of already
doing
but this is all automated and we're kind
of working on the assumption that this
goes away
at the end of this pandemic um and
you know i i don't know i'm kind of
undecided but i think that some people
are not
not so sure about this one way to look
at this is there's two ways of doing it
what
apple and what will traditionally be do
if you want to do exposure tracing is
you know someone's infected you then go
and ask them
who have you been in contact with and
then you get asked who they've been in
coming so you collect that data
when you know you need it the
alternative approach is
you collect all the data so that if you
need it
you can find what you want easily and
it's that difference between approach
if you've got all the data you can
probably get better quality out of it
but
do you need that data what are the
privacy gdpr
implications about that that you need to
take into account
will that then put people off using it
so some people
will be more happy to use one which is
relatively
low kept to their own device there's
some risk to it
but other people will say no i wouldn't
use that at all whereas
one where the government's effectively
collecting data everywhere you've been
may put more people off at which point
as you say
you've then got actual less data because
people say well i'm not putting that on
my phone
and if enough people do that you may end
up with a system that should be better
but will actually perform worse
because it's actually collecting less
data there's more people walking around
getting infected and passing the
infection on that you have no knowledge
about so that's the problem
i mean the sys either system is open for
abuse i mean we've seen people pranking
apple maps and google maps is transport
data by
strapping phones to dogs and so we could
have sort of
robot dogs running around the sort of
um country broadcasting that
they are a person with a key and then
people say afterwards they'll go and
mark them as infected so there needs to
be some sort of controls because
you could you can imagine causing chaos
you could sort of
send a little um drone around
flying over the heads of large parks
broadcasting infection messages and then
if you'd also need to be able to verify
this before that gets in steve
there are enough conspiracy theories
doing the rounds already let's not add
yeah you don't need to use 5g for this
most perfectly well
steve makes a valid point which is that
um
any system implementing this kind of
contact tracing has got to be very well
programmed because i mean you know
hypothetically
i secrete my phone somewhere near the
checkout of a of a supermarket
i get contact with dozens hundreds of
people throughout the day
and then i report that i've got some
virus right and then suddenly they're
all getting these things now
obviously i've got no real reason to do
that but we can't assume that everyone's
going to use
the system exactly how we intended it to
be used right so
you're going to have to build in some
kind of probably some kind of actual
medical check
right which has got to be tied into a
health service of some kind and
you know this all adds delays it does
get quite complicated quite quickly
the the thing is about this is it it
really requires pretty much 100 percent
um involvement people have to buy into
this
you have to get everybody who's a
smartphone to to buy into this or it's
not going to work probably what if only
of people had it steve well yeah i mean
this is the thing is i mean
the first thing to remember mine is even
if you've got 100 it may not work
because you're still relying on people
to self-isolate when they're told to and
things
and so on but obviously as less people
are using it you're going to catch
less interactions between people as they
move around if
10 of your population aren't using it
because they don't have a smartphone or
they don't like the privacy implications
of what's there
now in some ways that possibly wouldn't
be too bad because he probably catched a
second order
effect of that the okay dave's a refuse
nick he doesn't take his smartphone out
when he goes shopping he gets infected
he passes it on to mike who he bumps
into in the sort of
tesco around the corner um
mike does use it though he then gets ill
and everyone might be in contact with
get certified and say you've lost one
level but but of course if you then take
out if mike then becomes a refuse nick
because he doesn't like
the uh security implications of what the
particular app is being used you've now
got three levels
before you get things and so you can
start to see that actually as more
people
don't use it you get more problems with
coming on so the more people using it
the better it's going to be work so you
want
a system that gets as many people to use
it here
and i suspect if you were to model these
things i'm not an epidemiologist it's
not my sort of field
you would find that actually having less
information
but more people using it there's going
to be a balance to be found between do
you have more people using it with more
information at some point one is going
to be better than the other and it's
trying to model
what that is going to be i think it's
going to be an interesting question for
people who are developing these apps
the societies they're running in and
what they offer
yeah i mean i i don't think anyone knows
right at the moment i think the benefit
of the google and apple approach is that
it's quite low power and it just sort of
sits
on the operating system and eventually
will be app free so you won't need to
you won't need to necessarily have an
app installed for this api to exist
and that means that the uptake per
device will be quite high
for the compatible devices and for the
people that have you know sufficiently
powerful smartphones
um for the slightly more involved apps
there's big questions over
if they start using too much battery
because they're polling gps or too much
bluetooth
or something like this or constantly
reporting to the cloud
if you take a 20 battery hit per day
it's not going to be long before you
give up and uninstall and that drives
down the
not much you know the amount of use
which is exactly what we don't want
right so you know there are questions
over could you mandate something you
know make this sort of mandatory
it's going to be difficult right people
are not going to like that um you know
i suppose it's theoretically possible um
i mean i think i read somewhere and bear
in mind i can't remember
what the source was but it was something
about 80 need to be
have this app installed or being used
for it to be really effective
um you know there'll be some measure of
effectiveness below this
but if that's the case it's got to be
very fluid very
easy to use and there's got to be a real
sort of
push for everyone to kind of you do it
as a public service right and
you know whether or not that happens you
know i'm not sure yet
yeah i think there's an advantage in
sort of in getting people to buy in if
you've got the big tech companies which
are
long in particular cases had a strong
privacy
um application going on saying this is
working we want you to use it you're
going to get more buy-in there
than if you come up with something
random and you've got a lot of people
that don't trust your government for
example
um depending on what country you're in
and things so it's a sort of
an interesting sort of management of
what's going on
there i mean yeah it's interesting
well thank thanks both for getting
involved in this um
you know great to keep computer file
going while we're remote and
um hopefully my phone won't be pinging
yours anytime soon
see you later all right one of the big
downsides of kerberos
is that this is a bottleneck and it's
also a single big point of failure
we're all trusting that these keys are
coming from this one place
if that place gets gets compromised so
it'll send
packet one over to the machine that'll
take some time to get there but
eventually it'll get there and then it
will send